hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem rotting oranges
we're given an m by n grid where each
cell could have three different values
it could have a zero which represents
empty it could have a one which
represents a fresh orange or it could be
a two which represents a rotten orange
every minute that passes any fresh
orange that is four directionally
adjacent meaning either up down left or
right so if it's right next to a rotten
orange then that fresh orange will also
become rotten we want to return the
minimum number of minutes that must
elapse until no fresh orange exists but
it might be impossible you know suppose
if a fresh orange was actually not next
to any other oranges at all including
any rotten oranges then that fresh
orange would never become rotten so if
it's not possible then we can return
negative one but if it is possible we
return the minimum number of minutes
that it takes so you can see in this
example which is actually a very simple
one because we are only given a single
rotten orange but we could be given
multiple rotten oranges but in this case
we see that this is the rotten orange
right right now we're at time equals
zero and let's say one unit of time
passes now we're at time equals one what
happened well the adjacent oranges to
the rotten one also became rotten so
this is rotten now and this is rotten
now okay now another unit of time passes
it's time equals to what happened well
all the other oranges which were
adjacent to rotten oranges like these
two also became rotten okay now we're at
time equals three what happened well
this orange which is adjacent to a
rotten orange also became rotten now
we're at time equals four and this last
orange also became rotten because it's
next to a rock it's next to a rotten
orange so at time equals four
four minutes later all oranges are
rotten so we return four that's exactly
what they expect in this example let's
say this is the grid that we were given
and these orange things are the oranges
and let's say these two initially were
rotten what kind of algorithm can we do
to make sure that the adjacent oranges
also become rotten and then track the
time that it takes for you know each
layer to become rotten well you could
try a dfs right that's like the first
graph algorithm that most people try in
this case it's not really going to work
we run a dfs let's say on just one of
the or the rotten oranges let's say we
pick this one first okay we run a dfs on
the adjacent spots okay here's an
adjacent spot so this becomes rotten
this becomes rotten that's time equals
two then this becomes rotten at time
equals three then these two become
rotten at time equals four and then
lastly this one but that doesn't really
work because it took us five units of
time to make these rotten but that's not
actually what's gonna happen right these
two initial rotten oranges are
simultaneously going to be making the
adjacent oranges rotten right like after
one unit of time this orange is going to
become rotten from this one and this one
is going to become rotten from this one
after another unit of time this is going
to become rotten from this one and this
is going to become rotten from this one
and this is going to become rotten from
this one as well after two units of time
after three units of time this last one
is going to become rotten either from
the one above it or from the one to the
right of it so in three units of time
all of the oranges became rotten but we
didn't use dfs if you were watching
carefully you might have noticed that
the the main algorithm we were actually
using
is bfs breadth first search right which
is also a standard algorithm and the
reason it's helpful for us is because we
don't have to finish running dfs on a
single rotten orange we can run the bfs
algorithm simultaneously on multiple
sources at the same time so basically
what we're doing is running multi-source
bfs and usually bfs is implemented with
a queue data structure so basically what
we're going to be doing is initializing
our cue with the initial rotten oranges
we're going to pop through every initial
rotten orange and then we're going to
call that one unit of time and then to
our q we're going to add the next rotten
oranges so these two would not be in our
queue anymore but this one over here and
this one over here would then be added
to our q and then we're gonna you know
pop through those ones as well and then
call it our second unit of time and then
keep going like that but how do we know
when we're actually finished well once
our cue is empty then of course we can
stop but it's not guaranteed that we
will actually have made every single
orange rotten suppose there was an
orange all the way over here that's a
fresh orange it's not rotten yet of
course we know that these oranges are
going to become rotten but this is not
going to become rotten so basically
after our cue is completely popped what
we're going to notice is there is a
fresh orange remaining and the way we're
gonna know about that is because we
should keep track of how many fresh
oranges there are initially right in our
case i think there's about uh seven
fresh oranges right and then by the time
our bfs algorithm is done we're down to
one fresh orange because we still have a
positive number of fresh oranges that
means we were not able to make every
orange rotten and therefore we're gonna
have to return negative one as our
result but if we were able to
do that right let's say this orange
didn't exist we you know make all these
oranges rotten then we keep track of how
much time did it take us to make all of
the oranges rotten it was three units of
time i think so then we're going to
return three so that's the overall
algorithm as you can kind of tell from
the bfs it's multi-sourced but we're
still only going to be visiting each uh
orange each cell in our grid at most
once so we can say that the time
complexity is going to be n times m
where these are the dimensions of the
grid and i think in the worst case that
the memory complexity is also going to
be the same because we're going to be
using a q and all that so that's enough
for us to get into the code so let's do
that now okay so now let's code it up so
the first thing we're going to do is
initialize our deck it's going to be
empty initially we're going to also have
two more variables one is going to be
the time to keep track of how much time
has passed and another is going to be
called fresh to keep track of how many
fresh oranges we have at any given point
in time initially let's just set these
both to zero but let's actually iterate
over the entire grid and actually before
we do that it would be good to get the
dimensions of the grid so the number of
rows and the number of columns so now
let's iterate over the entire grid just
to do some pre-work the pre-work is
going to be doing two things at the same
time so we can just write some nested
loops to iterate over the grid one we're
going to be doing is counting the number
of fresh oranges right so if any cell in
the grid is equal to one remember that
ones represent fresh oranges so if this
is equal to one we can just increment
the number of fresh oranges the second
thing we also want to be doing is to
identify all of the rotting oranges
because remember we need to add them to
our queue so that we can actually run
the bfs in the first place right the
multi-source bfs so if any of these grid
cells are equal to 2 that means it's a
rotting orange and that means we can go
ahead and append it to our queue and by
append we're going to be appending the
coordinates of that rotting orange so
next what we're going to be doing is
running our while loop while our queue
is non-empty and we can say that if
fresh is also greater than zero right
basically if either of these uh you know
if our cube becomes empty or if fresh
equals zero then the loop is going to
stop if neither of those are true then
we're going to continue the loop so now
we have a certain number of rotten
oranges in our queue and we want to
actually pop every single one of them so
basically we're going to create another
loop while
you know let's say we have three oranges
in our queue then we're gonna iterate
through the loop three times we're gonna
pop those three oranges but at the same
time we're actually gonna be adding uh
the adjacent oranges to that q as well
marking them as rotten so that's why
we're creating the while the for loop
rather than saying while the queue is
non-empty because uh this will just take
a snapshot so for example if the length
of our queue is equal to three this loop
will execute three times even though
inside of the loop we're going to be
adding to the queue updating its length
but this uh you know the range function
isn't going to execute each time after
that we want to of course pop from the
queue and when we pop we're popping the
coordinates of the rotten orange at this
point we want to go through all of the
four adjacent spots for this orange so
what we're going to say is drdc
the difference in run difference in a
column in directions and we're actually
going to create a variable for this
outside of our loop and it's basically
the four directions that we could move
in so it's going to be pairs let's say 0
1 and 0
negative 1 and 1 zero and negative one
zero so these are the four directions we
could move in so that's what dr dc is
going to represent so
let's actually calculate what the row
would be so initially we're starting at
rc and then the you know adjacent spot
that we're looking at is going to be d r
plus r and d c plus c so this is one of
the four adjacent spots row column and
what we want to do with this position is
make sure that it's in bounds and that
it's a non-rotten orange so meaning that
it's a fresh orange let's actually
change this comment to that and it's a
fresh orange and then we want to make it
rotten so to save a bit of time i'm
actually just going to copy and paste
this so what we're doing here is
checking that the row
basically if the row is out of bounds if
it's less than zero or if it's too big
or if the column is out of bounds or
it's too big or the grid cell is
actually not a fresh orange if any of
these are true we're going to continue
to the next iteration of the loop
because that means this is either out of
bounds or it's not a fresh orange but if
it is a fresh orange and it's in bounds
then we want to make it into a rotten
orange so we can do that very easily
like this and we also want to add that
position to our queue so that row column
pair so that over the next iteration of
the while loop that we can include that
right even though we're appending to the
queue this portion of the you know for
loop isn't going to change right that
length was a snapshot we're not going to
continuously update that and last but
not least make sure to uh decrement the
number of fresh oranges because that's
one of the you know indicators of if we
can stop the algorithm or not and
remember this loop was going through all
of the rotten oranges and then the
adjacent
fresh oranges were being set to rotten
as well so that actually happened in one
unit of time so after that loop is done
executing we can increment our time by
one after uh this loop is finished then
it's time to return our result but how
do we know if we can return the time or
if we have to return negative one well
we can return the time if fresh is equal
to zero that means we made every single
orange rotten but else if it's not then
we have to return negative one that
means there's some oranges that we just
can't make rotten okay so that's the
whole code now lastly let's just run it
to make sure that it works and actually
i just noticed i made a couple of little
mistakes so over here on this line i
forgot one of the or statements so let's
add that as well and actually here we
have q.pop but remember we're actually
adding to the queue when we append we're
adding to the right side of the queue so
when we pop from the queue we want to
make sure we're popping from the left
because we want to pop you know the more
recently added oranges right that's why
we're taking this length if the length
was three we would want to pop the 3
oranges from the left side not the same
oranges that we're adding to the queue
so make sure that this is a pop left so
that being said let's run the code to
make sure that it works and as you can
see on the left yes it does and it's
pretty efficient so i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching